recently Joe I gave louia a shot at the
club you know after he heard about that
and you know though he called me up and
said hey do you mind if I do a spot and
I thought yeah sure no problem yeah I
like Lois wasn't arrested or convicted
of anything and yeah so I put him in he
did fantastic
Cosby's what do you think I said yeah
after that evening the backlash was just
unbelievable yeah you know I go how long
is enough what does this guy have to do
to try to get his career back right
buddy what is the backlash though
because the backlash is not you you're
the actual customers right no it was
they grab some female comics lab work
and that I'm working for me and that's
said that Mike locked the doors and put
a sexual predator on stage and it was
like everyone there enjoyed Louie and
you know I'm just trying to help a
friend gay he came in and he walked over
me I gave him a big hug easy yeah we got
no problem I got now you nitwit I said I
would have called you if that prick
right had given me a number he didn't
give me a he goes that's not right I go
I know that's what I told them
it said so I bring much they slice a
gentleman you know let's meet two thing
and everything here's a guy who who
didn't touch any women matter of fact he
touched himself that was the problem
they just happened to be in the room and
I said you could have jerked up and for
me as long as you get on my shirt my
shirt it's pretty expensive I said but
it is a beautiful you gave a job to the
people that turned on him he gave jobs
to yeah all right well there's a lot to
that story I don't know yeah there's a
lot to that story that would make him
look very different in a lot of these
people that are accusing him and one day
I think he's gonna tell us so he I had a
conversation with him about it it's it's
not his cut and dry as everybody thinks
everybody thinks he had power over these
women and he pulled his dick out and
started no there was a lot of there was
a lot of sex talk it was a lot of
flirting there was a lot going on it
wasn't that simple and he's very
convicted he's very contrite about it is
very very and he knows he [ __ ] up and
by the way he hadn't done anything like
that in more than a decade it was a long
time he just
he's got a kinky thing I I can't I can't
him
I can't reject up if the neighbors a
home I'm a wreck make weird faces honey
so it would be fun for anyone but I know
he's a good guy rapist he's my sexual
predator got Jenny buddy
he caught the worst part of the wave oh
yeah you know like if you're in the
ocean and you could be in the ocean on a
on a [ __ ] surfboard and you just
catch this little tiny wave and
everything's fine or you could [ __ ] up
and be in the right spot when that giant
wave comes and slams you in the head and
you have the same intention in the same
person and under in other times in
history he would have been fine he might
he would probably be fine today because
everything is kind of there's enough of
the females that have come out that have
been full of [ __ ] like Asia Argento and
the girl of Q's Chris Hardwick and then
Chris Hardwick released all these text
messages that show that she actually
cheated on him and she wanted him back
and she's just trying to punish him for
all this but these there's a few of
those situations now where people
realize well there's there's definitely
sexual predators and it's definitely bad
men and but there's also women or taking
advantage of this movement right and I
think the world is sort of like calmed
down a little like the Asia Argento
thought one was a big one hmm you know
when she it turned out that she was
calling Harvey Weinstein a rapist while
she was [ __ ] a 17 year old right that
she was she played his mom in a movie 10
years ago when he was seven it's like
Jesus correct like how could you how
could you have that kind of hypocrisy
but there's a lot of that in people that
are screaming for attention at the
frontal line of a lot of these things a
lot of them have like dark secrets
themselves yeah you know and they're
like wow these people that don't want a
guy like Louie to have a road to
redemption they don't want him to work
or even a guy like Aziz Ansari which is
even worse he had a bad date with a girl
like a bad date where she blew him like
three different times and didn't want to
keep going a bad date that sounds pretty
good for me it's pretty good no it's
better than no yeah the whole thing was
so crazy it's like there's there's more
than one side to every story like that
and to take someone's opinion or
someone's percept
something as 100% the actual event that
happened without any other evidence it's
kind of crazy I mean I don't think I
just I just think people have to
recognize that Louie in particular he's
been out of work he was out of work for
10 months I've lost all of his shows
people think he didn't suffer from them
30 million dollars Joe people that think
he didn't suffer are crazy
yeah you're crazy if you think you
should never be allowed to work again
well he's not a criminal jail right
right so what are you saying
and that was my point
I said sure Louie commit you know what
yeah I want to give him a fighting
chance and I guess he is back doing
clubs now and he's doing a lot of clubs
and he was very that's it it's always
trying to do she's trying to get his
life back yes you know he's building his
act again doing clubs and some [ __ ]
[ __ ] releases his whole act on
YouTube so now all that material has to
chuck away right so he was writing
during the time he was gone but not
performing right and then he puts
together you know an act that you know
look you know as well as anybody when
you have new [ __ ] it's got some goddamn
holes in it right I never written a bit
ever maybe one or two in my whole career
that was this that was the finished bit
when I first did it on stage maybe one
or two ever
they're always clunky and sometimes you
have ideas you're like why the [ __ ]
didn't even try that one unlike the
parkland shooter bit like he was doing
that bit right no it's in a very
unfortunate bit right especially people
who aren't in the club hear it and then
but who knows what that bit would have
been if someone didn't tape it yeah if
you gave him a year to work it out right
he probably would have figured out a way
to make it where it wasn't offensive and
it didn't [ __ ] on those kids in the same
way my best stuff was years ago before
cellphones and because I didn't know I
guess I just went out and now what I'm
onstage I'm constantly thinking oh don't
go that don't do that don't cross that
line because somebody you know and that
terrible feeling that oh it's horrible
it's heart of the funny [ __ ] that you
and I have laughed out hard was
something that someone definitely
shouldn't have said oh absolutely they
knew they shouldn't have said it that's
why they were saying it they were saying
it to make the audience laugh because
there
like I can't believe you [ __ ] said
that I'm not like he means so like
that's his actual no there's no
maliciousness behind a diet no you think
I want people to spend 30 40 bucks to go
out and that'd be pissed them off and
ruin your night would you like for your
date no you idiot I'm just trying to
make you laugh